county district attorney steve wolfson
joining us now to talk about a run for
reelection steve good to see you again
sir good to see you john thanks for
having me on your show all right well
let's just start pure and simple with
why you're running for reelection
well john you know we're at a critical
stage here in clark county uh covid hit
us all pretty hard
we lost people to covid a lot of people
got sick and it affected the justice
system as well
pretty pretty intensely so we're at a
critical stage we need a strong
experience and leadership i think i have
that and i'm willing to work for the
people for another four years let's talk
a little bit about that experience in
your time as as da so far what are your
pitches your that you've highlighted
during your time there smart reform
programs diversion programs
explore a little bit what the programs
are and how they have
have they worked as they've been put
into the justice system
well what we've learned over the years
is we have to be a little smarter about
how we do business in the criminal
justice system
so we've started redefining and
refocusing our priorities and one of the
things we've created is a program called
project redirect
it is a diversionary program it's the
first of its kind in nevada we realize
that most cases never go to trial and
most cases involving low-level
non-violent offenders get resolved in a
plea bargain they get misdemeanors or
sometimes even dismissals
but we want to offer certain treatment
programs to these people if there are
victims and restitution is owed we want
to collect that restitution so we
created project redirect which diverts
people out of the system assuming they
comply with a program of treatment
assuming they pay restitution if
appropriate assuming they stay out of
trouble and again these are for
low-level non-violent offenders so what
it does is it helps the system it saves
money
we're not charging people we divert them
from the charging decision to give them
a chance to get whatever treatment they
need uh pay the restitution
and and have a little informal probation
to earn this diversion it's the smarter
way of doing business so if that those
programs are sort of freeing up the
system a little bit or at least
lessening uh the burden on on going to
trial and so forth uh is there an effort
then to try to re-channel some of those
resources of the prosecutor's office
you've talked about a big backlog of
murder cases right now in the da's
office about 450 so how if you're
re-elected will you try and address that
backlog to try and get justice for
murder cases which is obviously a high
priority well we've already started john
on a number of things
by diverting some of the low-level
non-violent cases we're able to refocus
on what people care about the most which
is public safety
people want to feel safe when they're in
their homes and when they're going to
the supermarket so we're refocusing our
efforts on the violent crime
the cases involving homicides the cases
involving guns things like that because
that's what people care about most you
know we've seen an increase in that kind
of crime uh through the pandemic we saw
a big effort by metro police to try and
address that on the las vegas trip we've
seen some really uh tragic cases murder
cases in the last year or so
what from a prosecutorial standpoint can
your office do and can you do to
on a penalty standpoint point deter
similar crimes moving forward or at
least find try and get those cases to
trial
well john you have to realize as as most
of our viewers should realize that very
very few cases actually get to trial we
only do about 125 to 150 jury trials a
year and that's after filing 25 to 30
000 felony cases so 99.9 percent of
cases are settled with a plea deal
but what we're focusing on is what
people care about the most which is
the serious crimes
yes we have a backlog of murder cases
it's a serious problem we have about 450
450 pending murder cases now we cut into
that number pre-coven we got it down to
about 350 but covid had a drastic effect
on all of us
our homicide rate is up 50 percent the
first six months of this year compared
to last year so we've created a new
program we have a new homicide team with
our judges it's actually not that new
it's about three years old but what
we've done is we've selected four of our
most experienced judges to hear the
murder cases so we can focus on getting
those cases resolved we've also created
a new rule for settlement conferences
most cases settle but we need to bring
the parties together so they can talk
settlement so we've come up with some
new ways of doing things
sort of in line with the discussion of
of prosecuting our murder cases uh let's
talk about the death penalty um your
critics on the left your opponent uh
they are critical of your standpoint on
the death penalty in your
your view
do you have any
leeway or any movement in your point of
view on the death penalty do you think
there should be some changes obviously
it was discussed up in carson city
are you willing to discuss possibly
adjusting
your use of the death penalty in the in
prosecution well yes absolutely and i
have engaged in those discussions and i
continue to engage in those discussions
but a little history is appropriate
my predecessor filed almost 20 death
penalty cases a year
before i took office my first six seven
years i reduced that number to under 10.
so i cut the number of death penalty
cases in half and in the last two or
three years i've only filed a handful
because i recognize
the state of nevada has not executed
anybody since 2006 and just a couple of
years ago when a very violent person who
was convicted of a couple of homicides
where the jury
created not created but invoked the
death penalty and he wanted to be
executed and we still couldn't execute
mr dozer and he ended up committed
committing suicide in prison
i recognize that it is a controversial
issue but i also recognize that the
state of nevada is pretty split on
whether we should keep the death penalty
or abolish it
the polls i've been made aware of have
it at about 50 50.
so as the chief law enforcement officer
it's my job to enforce the law
and while the death penalty is still on
the books
in those very select cases
involving multiple homicides
one october is a perfect example
that killer got away too easy okay he
killed 60 people and then shot and
killed himself in my opinion he got off
too easy but if that man had survived
that's the kind of case we should have
the death penalty for or other similar
cases that are so egregious but i fully
recognize that they cost a lot of money
death penalty cases so we're continuing
to have discussions i've even suggested
perhaps a referendum
let's educate nevadans on both sides of
the issue so that nevadans can speak up
and voice their opinion
why keep it
why keep it the death penalty why
continue to in certain circumstances as
you mentioned keep the death penalty on
the
table um because there are those certain
circumstances where a vast majority of
people feel the death penalty is
appropriate okay and you're you're still
one of them i'm one of them in the
extreme cases yes but i
fully recognize that many homicide cases
don't fall into that extreme category
let's uh switch gears a little bit here
talk about
some cases
involving
police reform
you recently started a third grand jury
there has been some
questions raised about why grand juries
have been called in certain cases i'm
thinking of the officer kenneth laparra
case there's a couple other ones as well
the byron williams jorge gomez cases
educate the viewers if you can why you
called grand juries in those cases and
if you think that was the appropriate
method of trying to find resolution well
let's talk about grand juries in general
we do have three grand juries we've had
three grand juries now for a couple of
years
grand juries serve a very important
purpose there are some cases which
should be taken to the grand jury
cases involving children
where children are obviously scared
frightened of their accuser and by
taking a case before the grand jury we
can present children
to the grand jury and we can expedite
the prosecution of those cases
there are some cases that have special
needs that we take to a grand jury there
are some cases that we want to get into
the trial court as quickly as possible
there's a lot of serious cases john a
lot of cases involving homicides a lot
of cases involving sexual assault and a
lot of cases that are high profile that
we want to move through the system as
quickly as possible so i can talk about
the individual cases you mentioned
uh the lapera case that was the officer
we took that case to the grand jury
because we wanted to see if we could
move it into district court but that
grand jury
failed to find probable cause
so that's a body of citizens that
listened to the evidence and said we
don't think there's enough evidence to
proceed
how would you characterize the effort by
prosecutors in that case to actually
prosecute officer lopera
i had some of my best prosecutors
working that case
but the officer had good lawyers
themselves
these lawyers presented us with another
side to the story we are required by law
to present
what is called exculpatory evidence
to the grand jury that's evidence that
tends to negate guilt we are required by
law to present that which is what we did
so after a full
investigation and after a full
presentation to the grand jury that
grand jury saw fit not to indict that
officer
but as a grand jury correct away from
wrong it's only the prosecution that
makes the presentation correct that's
true so then how are all attorneys have
any input on how that grand jury makes
its ultimate decision if the only ones
they're hearing from is the prosecution
that's not true though because the
defense lawyers can present us with
requests of certain evidence to present
to the grand jury and we are required by
law to present
exculpatory evidence evidence that tends
to negate guilt the defense lawyers
presented us with that kind of evidence
we were required to present it to the
grand jury which we did so the grand
jury heard a lot of evidence and in
their infinite wisdom decided not to
file an indictment and we bring this up
because there's been a lot of discussion
as you know nationwide and here in las
vegas about uh
accountability for law enforcement
not that there are cases there's only
been a very few where an officer is
charged with a crime so
well
you know let me correct you there
because there's there's a mistake there
we are currently prosecuting about 15
police officers right now okay a lot of
people don't realize that for use of
force uh for a number of things domestic
battery right i'm not drug offenses well
but
the accusation which i think you're
referring to is that we don't charge
police officers with crimes we evaluate
police officers and whether or not they
committed crimes just like we do every
other citizen we have to determine
whether a crime was committed and
whether there's sufficient evidence to
move forward that's our ethical
obligation in some cases there's enough
and in some cases there isn't
one of the accusations that's been made
uh and it's kind of coming out in this
race so far is that you as as d.a uh
give sort of sweetheart deals to bigger
name attorneys in in las vegas uh david
chesnov among others
do you what do you say to those
accusations that when you're talking
about settling cases before they even
get to trial some of the high-powered
attorneys here in las vegas
get um
the benefit of the da's office
yeah i wonder
what those muckrackers which mr john
ralston referred to them as
whether or not they did enough research
because it's my understanding that mr
chesnov has challenged those accusations
i challenge those accusations as well
um there was an individual represented
by mr chesnov
that was found guilty of a very serious
felony dui involving death and injury
ask that gentleman if he thinks that his
lawyer got special treatment
because that gentleman is now serving a
significant prison sentence
there's another case in the system right
now involving a basketball player
where
a certain charge was dismissed
in a proceeding and we're still moving
forward on that case notwithstanding who
his lawyer is so i take exception to the
accusation that certain lawyers get
special deals
we evaluate cases on a case-by-case
basis john and we look at the strength
or weakness the merits of the case when
we decide how to handle it
kind of on that note about uh not those
specific cases but broadly when you
previously ran for for the position
for the prosecutor's office you
referenced the effort that you wanted to
make to try and cut down on the high
level of duis we see here in the valley
uh cutting down on gun crime from the
time you ran for election before to now
do you think your office has taken
enough steps to try and address those
issues i think we've taken a lot of
good steps
i have a dui
specialty team that focuses on these dui
cases
a lot of people
neglect to follow the law
and whether they consume alcohol legal
drugs or illegal drugs
or whether they're speeding and driving
recklessly or all of the above
we prosecute those cases vigorously i am
sorry to say that too many people are
still
breaking the law and we're putting
people in prison but to answer your
question
there's always more you can do
whether it's education whether it's
public service announcements i really
think that we need to do more
we're a community here john i've been
here 41 years
i met my wife i've raised a family here
i love las vegas
i don't like to see harm to come to
people but i think it's a community
effort i really think that the private
sector needs to step up perhaps pay for
some more education public service
announcements get the word out more that
if you drive while impaired and you
cause injury or death you're going to go
to prison
crystal ball if you're reelected to the
district attorney's office um what does
your office need
in order to move forward
well like a lot of government
departments and resources
well we are um
a prosecutor's office that when you
compare us to other prosecutors offices
in major metropolitan areas
like maricopa county or los angeles
county
i believe we don't have the same
resources that other areas do we do the
best we can i understand that everybody
would like more resources but i think
what i said a few minutes ago john about
re-prioritizing and redefining
what is most important is a great step
forward we've been doing that for years
is a great step forward in meeting the
needs of this community what would you
want to see whether it's funding or
staffing whatever the case may be where
would where should those resources in
your opinion be put moving forward what
would you like to add enhance well i
think we need more police officers okay
the police department and i'm not going
to speak for the sheriff but they're
having
some challenges with recruiting
a lot of officers are retiring for a
number of reasons
my office i can always use more
prosecutors i can always use more
resources to focus on what's important
most to people which is the battle
against violent crime
district attorney wolfson appreciate you
joining us thank you very much questions
please stay in touch during the election
thanks for having me on your show